et tout le monde ne parle que de ça le
variant delta qui menacent de
faire revenir la pandémie on avait dit à
l'automne ce sera peut-être cet été 30%
des contaminations actuels sont déjà dû
à ce variant et la question se pose de
savoir s'il faut pas accélérer la
vaccination voire de la rendre
obligatoire le risque c'est la fracture
vaccinale c'est une drôle d'expression
on connaît plutôt la fracture du tibia
et du péroné
cette fracture là et bien c'est celle
qui pourrait opposer deux catégories de
français
écoutez les explications de gilbert de
ré il est chef du service néphrologie à
la pitié salpêtrière
le vrai problème qui va se poser la
rentrée c'est la fracture maximale
parce que imaginez un instant qu'on a
une remontée des hospitalisations
significative et des moeurs
significative alors qu'on sait que
lorsqu'on est vaccinée on est protégé et
que ce qui contribue à l'épidémie
sernhac et non vaccinés est ce qu'on va
refermer le payer alors que qu à 50 60
70 % la population est vaccinée non les
le pays peut pas être fermé on va donc
est dans un cas de figure compliqué
c'est ce que j'appelle la fracture
vaccinale qui va être que x % la
population va être concerné par les
mesures alors cette fracture elle peut
opposer les français entre eux il ya à
peu près la moitié de la population qui
a été vaccinée à l'intérieur même de
certaines catégories professionnelles là
aussi à des oppositions et je pense en
particulier aux professions de santé
autant chez les médecins
le niveau de vaccination est très élevé
autant chez les infirmiers et encore
plus chez les aides soignants il est
moindre
par exemple dans les ehpad 43% donc
presque la moitié des personnels n'est
pas encore vaccinés d'où la question
faut-il contraindre faut-il rendre la
vaccination obligatoire pour l'instant
le projet du gouvernement
ça semble oui on peut rendre
obligatoires les vaccins pour le
personnel des établissements de santé en
tout cas si au mois de septembre le
niveau de vaccination n'est pas
suffisamment élevé en revanche c'est
exclu en tout cas pour l'instant
pour le reste de la population comme
olivier ferrand l'a rappelé et c'était
sur bfm tv aujourd'hui une contreuse
robin nous ne consacrons pas les
français à se faire vacciner la
vaccination n'a pas à être obligatoire
en population générale
en revanche nous faisons tout pour
vendre le vaccin disponible pour
rassurer pour lever les ambiguïtés les
inquiétudes là où elle existe et nous
comptons aussi sur chacun d'entre vous
qui êtes vacciné qu'ils avaient
confiance qu'ils avaient l'expérience de
cette vaccination pour convaincre autour
de vous alors un dernier élément
d'information avant de lancer le débat
qu'est ce qu'en pensent les français
c'est l'objet d'un sondage hoxha qui a
été réalisé pour france info et le
figaro les français semble t il selon ce
sondage sont largement favorables à la
vaccination obligatoire pour les
soignants 72% est favorable en revanche
c'est beaucoup plus balancé pour la
population générale 58% il est favorable
contre 42% qu'il y est opposée sagana
diaries c'est c'est vous la voyez venir
vous aussi cette espèce de
d'affrontements entre les français
vaccinés et ceux qui ne le serait pas
oui je pense qu'il ya un clivage qui va
t'il va naître est inévitable puisque
une épidémie effectivement relève
considération collective et donc il est
tout à fait normal que la société
s'emparent de ce genre de débats parfois
pour revenir sur l'action de la
vaccination
je suis assez navré est atterré pour
pour rester polie que le personnel
soignant qui est celui qui te donner
l'exemple
n'est pas un taux de vaccination
exemplaire est supérieure à la
population puisque c'est quand même un
public qui a un rôle spécifique c'est le
public qui a quand même milité pour
mettre en place les restrictions
sanitaires appropriées pour protéger les
plus fragiles et aujourd'hui quand vous
vous rappelez ce chiffre les ehpad
c'est à dire que qui héberge donc les
personnes les plus exposées au risque du
corps d'un virus que 42 % du personnel
dans les ehpad n'est pas vacciné je vous
coupe une seconde pour préciser que ce
chiffre de 43% de non vaccinés a été
donnée par santé publique france le 21
juin donc peut-être que ça a un peu
progressé depuis
en tout cas il reste deux là mais ça
reste tout à fait insuffisant maintenant
ceci étant dit je pense que dans une
société constitutionnel la fin ne
justifie pas les moyens c'est à dire que
moi je ne suis par principe opposée à
une contrainte légale en matière de
vaccination je pense que la liberté
vaccinale doit prévaloir en revanche il
faut que ce soit une liberté réciproque
qu'il faut rappeler que la liberté ça
dans les deux sens concrètement ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire liberté pour les
uns d'être insouciant éventuellement
avec le même mais liberté pour les
autres aussi de se protéger contre
l'insouciance des premiers concrètement
ça voudrait dire que je suis favorable à
ce que les employeurs par exemple et le
droit de conditionner l'accès à leur
établissement à une vaccination et que
l'absence de vaccination soit un motif
légitime de licenciement par exemple
alors on n'est pas dans la contrainte
légale il s'agit pas de mettre en prison
ou de d'infliger une amende à ceux qui
auraient refusé de signer qu'une
inversion dans leur corps ce serait
complètement liberticide en revanche je
trouve je regarde avec bienveillance la
possibilité d'une saine pression sociale
qui consisterait à dire voilà tu es
libre de faire vacciner ou pas en
revanche moi je suis libre de textes
klur de mon établissement ce qui n'est
pas vaccinée or aujourd'hui le problème
c'est que la législation sociale
française interdit l'exercice cette
pression sociale puisque les employeurs
n'ont pas le droit de conditionner ou de
licencier un salarié au motif qu'ils
n'auraient pas été vaccinés
je pense que si on rétablissait cette
liberté contractuelle ça engendrerait
une saine pression sociale susceptible
d'accroître paisiblement la couverture
d'affilée dans le pays est vraiment une
conversation possible richard houis
qu'on pourrait imaginer une pression
généralisée d'ailleurs en réservant
l'accès au train
aux salles de cinéma ou au restaurant
aux gens vaccinez avec les qr codes et
les applications se serait concevable
et pourquoi on ferait davantage que ce
que demande le pass sanitaire le passé
ni tard il vous demande pas
nécessairement d'être vacciné il vous
demande de produire sinon un test qui
permettent de dire que vous n'êtes pas
contaminer donc pourquoi on demanderait
la vaccination d'abord la vaccination
complète de doses où la vaccination que
windows est pourquoi que windows
pourquoi deux et pourquoi 3 si on est
dans des situations d'extrême fragilité
ou pourquoi que une parce que c'est avec
le john seine bref moi je pense qu'il ya
le passé ni terre et qu'il faut quand
même qu'on réagisse de manière cohérente
avec ce qu'il ya dans le passé à lutter
aujourd'hui le passé à lider c'est
l'autorisation d'avoir accès à des
choses si on est vaccinés ou si on peut
produire un un test qui montre que vous
n'êtes pas porteur d'un virus au moment
où vous allez vouloir accéder à un lieu
à un événement ou autres donc pourquoi
elle est plus loin que le pass sanitaire
que je jeu en ce moment je me dis il ya
ce cadre là après sur le débat pour
installer partout ça vous choquerait pas
si par exemple on mettait un contrôle à
l'entrée du figaro pour vérifier que les
les gens qui rentrent dans l'immeuble
sont vaccinés ou un test pcr récent
négatif moi je suis enfin franchement je
serais pas surpris à partir du moment où
l aérés du 12e arrondissement
non mais alors c'est compliqué parce que
vous avez une notion de service public
alors on peut le faire a effectivement
ça me gênerait ça me gênerait pas mais
il faudrait quand même que l'information
soit donnée bien en avant que les gens
ne découvre pas au moment où ils
viennent faire une démarche qu'il
fallait qu'ils aient soit un vaccin
opérant ou alors un test qui permettent
de les faire entrer il faut qu'on ait
vraiment un système d'information avant
dans une entreprise vous avez souvent
moins de personnes ou des moyens
d'informer qui sont beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus facile donc non je pense
que ce pass sanitaire va s'imposer après
on est pour ou on est contre il ya eu
tout un débat au parlement mais
aujourd'hui se passe va s'en va
s'imposer
donc est ce que ce n'est pas à travers
ce pas sanitaire qu'il faut qu'on avance
et qu'on crée un petit peu les mesures
et si on ne veut pas du passé sanitaire
moi je renvoie à ce que vous disiez tout
à l'heure on peut très bien ne pas se
faire vacciner on peut très bien ne pas
vouloir faire de test
mais après il faut pas non plus
s'étonner que certains lieux ne soit pas
accessible parce qu'en gros il ya aussi
le besoin de se protéger on a bien vu
qu'aujourd'hui même si ça va beaucoup
mieux il ya quand même avec ce variant
delta la possibilité que tout ne se
passe pas de manière aussi aussi
linéaire que ce qu'on avait évoqué
d'ailleurs dans les propos qui étaient
évoquées par la personne qui intervenait
dans l'extrait que vous avez montré avec
guillaume il ya un sujet quand même en
israël il ya un tout personnes à
vacciner qui est considérable et pour
autant il y a eu une remontée des à la
fois des tests positifs est alors
remonté relative mais quand même des
personnes en hospitalisation donc ce
n'est pas que voilà donc une situation
qui reste un peu fragile quand même on
vous pose la question sur twitter
va-t-on vers une fracture entre les
personnes vaccinées et les non vaccinés
et vous ne répondez oui à 78%
le débat est animé entre nos internautes
girardet estime que les personnes
vaccinées au son d'une intolérance folle
qui frise la démence
alors que chaoui libre nous dit les
personnes des victimes décédées ne
comprendront jamais l'égoïsme des gens
qui refusent de se faire vacciner
claudius considère que pour le personnel
médical il est logique qu'ils soient
vaccinés cela fait partie de l'éthique
de leur profession et puis micheline qui
nous dit on va vers une fracture car la
médecine n'a plus de secret
professionnel
alors peut-être sauf que en principe
tout ce qui est passeport sanitaires et
autres chars micheline va cet anonyme
donc la machine qui vérifie ne sais pas
qui vous êtes une garde pas les donner
est ce que vous seriez choqué sagana
ziari par un recond finement s'il devait
y en avoir un au mois de septembre au
mois d'octobre mais qui serait réservé
aux gens non vaccinés ce serait quand
même compliquées à mettre honneur mon
avis d'après de vue constitutionnel s'il
ya une rupture de l'égalité de swing est
quand même assez assez flagrante
le problème
du pur dans l'heure du premier conte
finale mais je centre les gens qui
étaient enfermés sous feu et les gens
peuvent voir qui est qui qui ça allait
travailler parce que c'était
indispensable si on a mené bien chez
radio moi j'étais opposé aussi au
premier confinement pour fournir et donc
là dessus je garde une consistance
c'est le problème aujourd'hui en fait de
la situation c'est que on a peur
finalement et à juste titre que les
personnes non vaccinées fasse courir un
risque aux à la collectivité donc toute
la question est comment finalement faire
entendre que ceux qui veulent rester
insouciant n'en paient le coût de leurs
errements en ayant recours en n'ayant
pas nécessairement recours à des mesures
coercitives et là je pense qu'il ya des
logiques on va dire - punitive qui peut
être mise en oeuvre par exemple on va
dire écoutez si vous n'êtes pas vacciné
la solution est là vous l'avez refusé
et pourtant vous venez encombrer les
hôpitaux eh bien vous ne serez pas
prioritaire par rapport à quelque chose
de plus grave
ou alors ou alors ou alors vous payez ou
alors vous payez c'est à dire que vous
payez on rentre dans une logique
assurantielle finalement un peu un peu
privé qui consiste à dire ben la
collectivité n'a pas à supporter ou le
coût des errements volonté des uns et
des autres ce serait à mon avis moins
liberticide de dire on va vous assigner
à la maison ça veut dire que je suis dit
encore une fois de faire ce que je veux
donc il ne s'agit pas d'enfermer les
gens je pense que le confinement est un
outil liberticide en revanche liberté va
avec la responsabilité et donc peut
aussi un dieu des mécanismes de
régulation et des pressions sociales
pour faire comprendre aux gens que si
jamais il se passe quelque chose de
dramatique et bien ils devront en payer
les conséquences de leurs erreurs et non
pas les les répercuter finalement sur
les autres ça ce serait ça serait fort
quand même on espère briques de dire aux
gens vous n'êtes pas vacciné m'avoue
passé après en réanimation en même temps
peut-être que ce serait efficace parce
qu'on l'a bien vu les gens se font
vacciner quand ils ont peur pourquoi est
ce qu'on arrive à un palier et l'a
probablement parce que beaucoup de
français se disent finalement je peux
attendre un peu parce que le virus est
moins méchant ouais mais c'est en fait
ça me fait pensé à deux choses enfin je
reviens à votre question mais en passant
par une première
l'obligation de vaccination pour le
personnel médical
mais pourquoi on l'a pas annoncé dès le
début pourquoi on attend aujourd'hui le
mois de juillet pour dire que ce serait
il va falloir la rendre obligatoire
pourquoi dès le début on l'a pas dit pas
parce qu'on voulait bah non parce que je
pensais ben non mais non il parce que
rien parce qu'aujourd'hui on a en gros
un moment où on est un peu en bascule
sur le taux de personnes qui vont se
faire vacciner on a encore des
vaccinations qui sont importantes à 500
ou 600 mille personnes par jour mais la
plupart cédés deuxième 12 en axant
cinquante mille ans première dose et que
c'est pas assez par rapport au rythme
conseils donnés pour vacciner l'ensemble
de la population et pour être tranquille
au début de l'automne donc en gros
aujourd'hui on essaie de trouver les
moyens c'est on va chercher vers les
jeunes aussi une possibilité pour faire
monter ce cette immunité collective
cette audi multi collections le cherche
avec les soignants mais il ya peut-être
des choses à dire dès le départ et moi
je trouve que c'est en tout cas que tout
ce qui est gênant et là c'est pareil sur
le vaccin
si on doit dire que celui qui se veut ne
se fait pas vacciner il aura des
conséquences à salon vaccination on
annonce au départ on change pas les
règles du jeu tout d'un coup en cours de
route
en dix ans ce qui était finalement
autorisé et qui n'a pas été blâmé on
avait dit que la vaccination ne serait
pas obligatoire pour les français et
maintenant on changerait de pied et ça
deviendrait quelque chose d'obligatoire
mais on change de vue parce que
l'épidémie revient l'épia les menaces de
revenus alors l'épidémie revient calmons
nous l'équidé l'épidémie elle est quand
même plutôt en train de régresser par
rapport à ce qu'on a connu
on a plutôt la aujourd'hui des taux
d'incidence et on a des taux
d'hospitalisation qui sont bas le but du
jeu c'est d'essayer de maintenir ça et
qu'on n'ait pas une quelque chose qui
repart donc qu'il ya à la fois la partie
la partie de la vaccination mais
rappelez-vous on a toujours dit que la
vaccination ne serait pas l'alpha et
l'oméga dans un premier temps qu'il
faudra et continuer à tester continuer à
isoler et continuer à travailler sur ça
tant qu'on n'a pas ça je pense que moi
c'est quelque chose de global mais
changer les règles en cours de jeu je
trouve que c'est tout à fait étonnant et
les personnels soignants s'il fallait
que ce soit obligatoire fall et le tir
dès le départ on change pas comme ça
tout d'un coup le risque zéro n'existe
pas mais on sait quand même que la
vaccination est l'instrument le plus
efficace et le moins coûteux
disons dès le départ à disposition
maintenant effectivement je pense que si
on n'a pas usé de l'obligation au début
ce parce qu'on voulait à juste titre est
dans une logique de proportionnalité et
miser le plus possible sous la
responsabilité individuelle ce qui est
tout à fait bienveillant je ne vais pas
reprocher à un gouvernement d'être
modéré dans l' usage de la coupe de la
contrainte en revanche c'est vrai que on
peut aussi se demander comment innover
finalement pour persuader les gens se
faire d'amis nous allons aux etats unis
c'est très intéressant ce qui se passe
vous avez un pays qui déploient des
trésors d'inventivité pour inciter les
gens à se vacciner
parfois on en organisant des loteries
nationales alors celui qui seul celui
qui est vacciné de participer à la
loterie ensuite la fin ils gagnent
éventuellement appris les entreprises
parfois paient leurs collaborateurs les
leurs salariés pour se faire vacciner
donc il n'y a pas que le bâton il ya
aussi la carotte et c'est vrai que je
m'étonne pour ma part qu'il n'y ait pas
une campagne de communication va dire
plus
plus spectaculaire pour inciter les gens
à vacciner comme on peut le voir dans
deux pays où des célébrités sont
mandatés pour ce faire pitié dans la
caméra afin donc essayons de séduire moi
je pense que la coercition de vraiment
rester là en dernier dernier dernier
recours et qu'il ya d'autres solutions
mettre en oeuvre ce qui est intéressant
c'est que vous arrivé à la même
conclusion mais avec des justifications
différentes mais vous êtes plutôt contre
l'un et l'autre le des obligations ou
des mesures trop contraignantes pour le
je le voudrais de laisser le dernier mot
jean bafouille à nos internautes
accèdent qui nous dit dans le personnel
médical tout un bloc se sent plus
fonctionnaires que soignant bon ben
voilà c'est un point de vue il est
exprimé
ça fait sourire ferghana ziari et olympe
nous dit il faut aller vers une
responsabilité des jambes c'est une très
belle conclusion du